you
you
hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast
understanding your biosafety cabinet
three approaches to improving safety in
the laboratory I'm Suzy Valdez of lab
routes and I will be your moderator for
today's event today's educational web
seminar is brought to you by labyrinth
and sponsored by lab Camco for more
information on our sponsor please visit
them at lab Khan cocom now let's get
started before we begin I want to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click on
the send button will answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation if you have any
trouble seeing or hearing this
presentation simply click on the support
tab found at the top right of your
presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of your presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
those credits I'd like to now introduce
our presenter David latisha a product
manager at lab Khan Co Corporation David
welcome you may now begin your
presentation thanks so much for the
introduction and thanks everyone is
taking a portion of your day out to
learn a little bit more about biosafety
cabinets are obviously a well-known
important tool in many laboratories and
so today we're going to look at just
some basics about some of the biosafety
cabinet options and types and when they
should be used and taken advantage of
also we're going to talk about a couple
of ways to look at the types of
biosafety cabinets in relation to user
safety and and features and functions of
each of those biosafety cabinets and and
how users can understand what
happening with a biosafety cabinet
suppose and they may know we'll also
look at some general practices that
should be taken with biosafety cabinets
on a daily basis a weekly basis monthly
basis in a lifetime basis to better
prepare you for things that might come
up with your biosafety cabinets over
their lifetime so just again a quick
highlight well we'll talk about the
different biosafety cabinet ice for
class 2b SCS with a little bit of
background on biosafety in general
looking at how to interpret some of the
things that your biosafety cabinet is
telling you and then also just again
looking at a user responsibility to make
sure that biosafety cabinets in your
possession are operating correctly and
keeping you safe and keeping your work
contamination free so let's let's step
back a minute and just talk about some
of the different uses for biosafety
cabinets it's right in the name because
is self-explanatory they are really
focused on on containing and controlling
biohazardous material and biohazardous
material can come from many different
things living aerosol or particulate it
could be a virus or bacteria or another
pathogenic life derived material and
that might mean you know working with
samples that come from animals or humans
or even plants there are a lot of really
good resources that go way more in depth
into requirements for safe handling of
biosafety or bio biological organisms
especially pathogenic organisms one of
the best for North American based people
was particularly United states-based
people is the CDC's bmbl guide which
talks about laboratory design and
specifics for even individual organisms
and how to handle them safely another
great resource for anyone using a
biosafety cabinet is the NSF ANSI
standard 49 guideline on on biosafety
cabinet design and while the CDC
document is free the NSF stay
it is paid for but there is a section of
it that's made available to all users
called annex II which contains a
significant amount of information that's
that's free and open to the public that
has great information on how to maintain
your BSC things to look for how to
select one and it is a great resource
for anybody who's responsible for
biosafety cabinets
you'll also find if you go into the lab
Kong Co website we have lots and lots of
good articles and resources to talk
about everything from different types of
BSC s2
should I use a UV light too what are
some applications for my biosafety
cabinet that I might not know about and
perhaps want to learn more about so all
good resources definitely recommend
accessing them at some point in time
during your your time working with pot
safety cabinets so one of the other
things I just want to hit on real quick
you'll see in some of the slides are
just a mention of biosafety levels now
on this slide I mentioned that the
designations come from the CDC with
respect to the levels and requirements
for different types of measures to keep
a laboratory safe these do vary
depending on where you might be so if
you're sitting in Canada certainly you
know that there's different guidelines
free and available as well and depending
on your country you may find the same is
true where if the CDC doesn't apply
there may be another leading document so
a good good starting point and certainly
a reference for this this presentation
is the CDC bmbl and just to go into that
a little bit more clearly there are four
key classification levels for biosafety
VSL one two three and four
as you look at them the lowest means the
least pathogenic or at least risky up to
bsl-4 which would be highly pathogenic
non curable diseases such as Ebola for
instance so you'll see those terms used
throughout but enlarge the the biosafety
cabinet the VSL level dictates what
kinds of equipment and safety
precautions you need to take
so the first approach I want to talk
about in approving improving lab safety
by better understanding your biosafety
admin is to know the classifications and
the types of biosafety cabinets that are
offered if you look at all of the
biosafety cabinets made in the world
across all manufacturers you'll find a
lot of key concepts that are similar
between them all and they're kind of
outlined in these three different
classifications of protection so
paramount to all biosafety cabinets is
that there are ventilated biological
containment device is a simply put is is
a containment device that's moving air
flow in directions to help keep your
work sterile and your self safe so we
can break those up into three categories
the first one is personnel protective
air flow you'll notice the the video
showing right now is just an image of
someone will work with their hands
inside the biosafety cabinet but if you
were to measure airflow on the outside
of the cabinet there's actually airflow
coming in towards the biosafety cabinets
into the front grille which draws
aerosols away from a user's breathing
respiratory area at their body and keeps
them contained you'll also notice the
video that's playing this is
representative of product protection and
it comes in the form of laminar or
unidirectional down flow air which is
moving in a straight consistent velocity
and direction to help sweep away
contaminants from your work and it's
coming from a HEPA filter which we'll
get into in a second here but on the
this air is very pure and helps keep
cell cultures clean helps keep sterile
drugs clean and contamination free from
the work that might be adjacent within
the biosafety cabinet not so visible
here but also an important consideration
is the environmental protection offered
by a biosafety cabinet and as you see
there's smoke being generated in this
image going down into a channel and then
in some cases being directly exhausted
to the outside
some cases recirculated but before any
of this air that is potentially
contaminated re-enters the room or an
exhaust system it's going to pass
through an exhaust at the filter so as
to purify this the the contaminants
before going moving that air somewhere
outside of the biosafety cabinets so for
all of that air flows there's got to be
a driving force and that's done in a
biosafety cabinet using a blower over
the years many different technologies
have been used most prominent and most
favorable and common right now is that
an ECM blower or a DC powered blower
these are similar to what you might find
in an extremely high efficiency furnace
or air conditioning system they
essentially run more energy efficient
they're quieter and cooler because
they're using less energy they're also
highly reliable with lifetimes in the 10
to 20-year range for biosafety cabinets
which is effectively the life of a
typical biosafety cabinet they also
sometimes are outfitted or programmed
with a monitoring software that can look
at the output from the biosafety
cabinets air flows and say am i running
exactly where I need to be if not they
can automatically make changes so that
the air flow for inflow and down flow
remains within the calibrated range from
its initial or or yearly certification
there's also an important part of a
biosafety cabinet which is the
filtration which keeps biological
hazards from and escaping the biosafety
cabinet it also helps to purify air
going down into the work surface area so
that you can not only protect yourself
but work in a sterile environment and
this is a cutaway of a b2 biosafety
cabinet but all Class two models have a
supply and exhaust filter to help purify
that air before entering critical areas
either the lab or back into the work
area the function of a HEPA filter is
pretty basic it's a high-efficiency
particulate air filter there are many
different grades and levels of HEPA
filters but what you'll find in
biosafety cabinets is a filter that's
typically 99.99% effective against point
three micron particles which means that
most biological constituents are much
larger than point three microns and will
be more effectively trapped by a HEPA
filter we have a couple of great
articles on our website if you want to
learn more on HEPA filtration but in
this instance just highlighting the two
locations for the filters within a
biosafety cabinets they're made out of
glass fibers that are woven and then
folded and for lots of surface area and
you can see in those supply folks
they're shown here it's stuck into an
aluminum frame this means that while the
frame is very very durable the the
fibers are actually quite fragile so
HEPA filters need to be treated with
extreme care when they're either being
inserted or pulled out of the biosafety
cabinet by a certifier and also if you
happen to perhaps you know want to do a
deep cleaning on the biosafety cabinet
and you remove the diffuser on the
inside of the pse you need to be
extremely careful though so it's not to
not spray any liquid on the on the
filter or not touch the filter either
here's just a quick shot of what I have
the filter looks like and you can see
there's lots and lots of ridges here
that's all the folds and done with those
translate into is a significant amount
of surface area for particulates to load
giving a biosafety cabinet
along have the filter life so if we make
all of that together we end up with a
class two BSC two filters sterile air
for the work work environment and then
also protection for a user but there are
different ways that we can move that air
through a biosafety cabinet depending on
what's used in the biosafety cabinet
experimentally maybe regulatory
requirements for exhaust and and and you
can see those are all represented here
in blue and red colors now blue is going
to represent over these next several
slides areas where it's safe to work
with microbiology microbiological
substances particulates but not
chemicals because that air is either
recirculated back into the room or back
into the cabinet at which which means
that it may be potentially hazardous to
have high volumes of chemicals chemicals
are not trapped by HEPA filters they are
only particulate filters so if you are
working in a biosafety cabinet just
understand that only the particulates
will be trapped but any chemical gases
will not be trapped so the first and
probably most common type of biosafety
cabinet is what's known as a class 2
type a to BSC and chances are if you've
ever worked with a tissue culture hood
or a bio cabinet it's been in a - and
there's a cross-section here showing
some of the airflow these typically have
an inflow rate of about 100 feet per
minute
typically 105 nominally they're approved
for all BSL levels per CDC with the
exception of course that if you're
handling Ebola you may need a positive
pressure bubble suits a - biosafety
cabinets if you look at the cross
section push some of their air back into
the work surface down down flow air and
some out of the biosafety cabinet is
exhaust air sometimes this is referred
to as a 70/30 exhaust recirculation
split so that number does vary from
every manufacturer and every mom
but understand that part of the air is
being recirculated so what that means is
if you're working with biological
aerosols particulates then you're safe
so those will be trapped on the hepa
filters but if you're handling chemicals
in any amount some a portion of those
chemicals will be brought back into the
work surface area so you need to be
mindful and do a safety risk assessment
of the volume of chemicals being used
and potentially consider exhausting this
BSC with a canopy or moving to a
different type of biosafety cabinets so
as a representative of the of the
airflow and the work area where it's
safe to work with chemicals you can see
this entire area it's blue which means
that it's not a great idea to work with
anything more than very minutely levels
of chemicals within the workshop this
area now I mentioned the canopy design
that's a transition adaption for the top
of the biosafety cabinet I can connect
the biosafety cabinet to of building
exhaust and it's per NSF forty nine it's
recommended for radionuclides my new
volumes of volatile chemicals and toxic
chemicals as an adjunct to microbiology
so in no sense is a biosafety cabinet
first a fume hood and then second a
biological law hood
is really designed to be a biological
hood first that duct design looks
something like this and the the point of
the slide is just to be aware that a
biosafety cabinet can tie into building
ductwork depending on its size style a2
s and C ones have the easiest ability to
do that and they always need to be
connected to a remote blower at the
distal end of the exhaust whether that's
shared between many B SES or
a single blower per BSE can depend on
the building design but in any
installation of a biosafety cabinet that
is vented it always has to have a remote
blower typically located on the roof top
so you might be thinking well there are
applications where you might need to use
more chemicals than just a small my new
to trace amount and so over 30 years ago
now
a style of biosafety cabinet came about
classified not as an aid but actually is
a type b cabinet and there are two types
there's a B 1 and a B to the B one is
shown here and and their intent was to
provide a total exhaust pathway for
chemical safety B 2 is most common and
you can see here in this design very
similar to an A it's got a minimum of
100 people and feed per minute in flow
velocity that's the air flowing into the
front of the cabinet keeping you safe
it's safe for different types of BSL
work and it's it's for intended to to
somewhat marry the merits of a fume hood
into a biosafety cabinet by being 100%
exhaust which means that the biosafety
cabinet must at all times be ducted to
the outside to provide chemical safety
and sometimes that can be costly because
you're exhausting quite a bit more air
about twice as much as an a - when
vented and it can be difficult to
maintain because the b2 style biosafety
cabinets and b1 so that matter don't
have an internal blower that easily
maintains a constant volume supply to
the duct so if you're building exhaust
has a fluctuation that will directly
impact the b2 and could cause
containment issues without having a
redundant backup blower now if we look
at the work surface area you can see
working at a b2 is a better fit for
larger volumes of chemicals as you can
see this entire area is red which means
that it's suitable for larger volumes of
chemicals because no air is being
recirculated and there's no chance for
explosive risk for our accumulation of
chemicals within the work zone and so if
you do have large open containers or
mixing large volumes of chemicals a b2
is a better fit than an A - when vented
but there are some comps to be aware of
when selecting these BSC s that do
directly impact not only the energy
costs and in complex complexity of the
ventilation but also workplace safety so
you can see that while you do have
chemical costs you do have
the added costs of the dedicated exhaust
the operational safety that's tied to
the blower being building controlled not
biosafety cabinet controlled situations
can impact use your safety and then lots
of design and installation and
operational cost and the inflexibility
of the bee is a key component of their
design as well so if you ever wanted to
use the biosafety cabinet without
inventing and using precious expensive
energy
you simply cannot because of the b2 will
not start up and it will just be a dead
air box that won't provide any personal
protection so there's a different type
of biosafety cabinet that can marry the
two together it's known as a type c1
this is the most recent addition to the
NSF standard within the last five years
and it is a similar in that it has
identical in flow requirements but it's
flexible in that it can be a type A to
style BSC where recirculates air or can
operate in a b mode where it has a
dedicated hundred-percent exhaust but
doesn't require all of the dedicated
duct design or the strong exhaust
requirements for b2 because it's
providing constant air volume into the
exhaust for biosafety cabinets these are
easy to duct and connect to a building
system you can have a fume hood on the
same exact pathway as this BSC type
whereas a fume hood connected to a b2
would be very difficult to balance and
there are also some strategies with the
internal blowers that can help promote
and enhance user safety by allowing for
stability of the biosafety cabinets
airflow in the event of a building
fluctuations you'll see here the one
unique point about the c1 is that it has
a keen designated area for 100% exhaust
when in B mode you'll see that noted by
the red highlighted area on this on the
slide and when this BSE is connected to
building exhaust if you have to work
with any volumes of chemicals that are
normal or larger work in the central
dish
and it's a well-defined area that that
helps users
understand where they can and cannot
work with with chemicals safely
so if you were to look at the c1 and
it's flexibility and safety so the first
point I want to make is that it's a
flexible biosafety cabinet that can be
used in either A or B mode so you don't
have to make a commitment in one way or
the other one purchasing a cabinet and
it will always be safe provided that
users understand the application that
they're working with and what mode the
biosafety cabinet needs to be in it also
saves a lot of energy because it's got
air flow exhaust about half of a b2 so
lots of lots of green quality to the
biosafety cabinet while also maintaining
a full protection by having 100%
exhausted air and for if you're in an
old building or in a complex design you
can use this type of biosafety cabinet
to enhance the the ability to connect
into ventilation without much
frustration if you're familiar with B
cabinets you may have experienced some
of their challenges and because of C and
an a both provide constant volume to the
ducts there is a less challenge with
exhausting them and it also simplifies
the process for selection of a BSc so if
you are frequently change usage for your
bio cabinet from needing to have
chemical protection or you're evolving
your research and you don't know where
it's going to lead you you may end up
with a biosafety cabinet that
requirement changed throughout your work
well c 1is is designed to grow and adapt
with you
and not in this presentation but if
you'd like or a couple of great videos
on our website explaining some of the
really interesting alarm and safety
protection features that see ones offer
by running for additional time and
keeping the the biosafety CAD
operational in the event of a building
fluctuation or the system the building
system dying so enough time to clean up
safely and get out of the biosafety
cabinet without being contaminated
yourself or contaminating others
so just a quick snapshot looking at the
biosafety cabinets and their cost
performance so here's an A - roughly
over 15 years you're looking at about
five thousand dollars to operate and
maintain with electricity and service
and if you compare that to a in a ducted
fashion - between an A and a C the C is
nominally more expensive but offers
quite a bit more safety from chemicals
and can be flexible with you more
importantly if you look at Asti versus B
you'll see the costs are quite of quite
large for a b2 versus a c1 not to
mention the additional requirements that
having dedicated ductwork in a large
exhaust fan so it's it's quite a burden
on a building not on not including the
costs of operation which may not be a
part of the initial purchase
consideration so one other thing I want
to talk about is just a common question
we ask is when when do you need to vent
a BSc well ultimately you need to do a
risk assessment with your work and what
chemicals you're working with but if you
have a a - these are a couple of the
things that are suitable for for that
type of BSC to be vented it would be
odorous samples small volumes of
chemical solvents and small
concentrations of volatile chemicals as
well so really really smaller volumes if
you have larger chemical volumes or
something that's particularly
carcinogenic and you don't want any
recirculation into the work area where
your hands are a c1 or a b2 makes a
great fit for exhaust
all right point to improving your
biosafety cabinet knowledge and
understanding and safety is not only
knowing the types of BSC s and how they
function and if your work is correct but
also understanding after you made that
selection understanding what your BSC is
trying to tell you there they're
obviously there are lots of improvements
that have happened in the industry to
help users become safer users but there
are still a lot of technologies out
there that don't clearly represent
information so here's a just a fun look
into lab Conoco past and you'll see two
iterations of biosafety cabinets here is
the first one on the left is several
decades old and the one on the right is
about 20-25 years old these are both
obviously discontinued models but if we
look at their control panels you'll see
some pretty basic information on the
left you'll see you've got on and off
buttons for the blower in the light and
then there's also a small gauge of magna
he lit gauge for many he lit gauges that
sometimes is called and that shows the
static pressure build-up of the of the
biosafety cabinets filters as
particulates from work and the
environment load and and that is the
saddest indication of the performance of
the biosafety cabinet there's no mention
of airflow or filter status just engage
which can be highly variable from filter
type from biosafety cabinet design etc
so while it's important to look at that
gauge it's very difficult to understand
what it's telling you now on the right
you'll see there's on/off switch for a
light and a blower and then a red dot
and that just tells you that something's
wrong with the airflow but it doesn't
really tell you really much of anything
about if the airflow is too fast to slow
is it within range but maybe not perfect
and so these are these are things that
are on biosafety cabinets that are
indicators that something that's wrong
but may not tell you the full story so
if you have an older biosafety cabinet
please be aware that these are not
replacements for our these are not
not full communicators for exactly how
the biosafety tent is performing you do
need to seek out a third-party
certification and make sure that it's
probably on a more relevant frequent
schedule than their typical one year
just ensure that the pass safety cabinet
is operating safely
so where do vsi's lands a day well if
you have a biosafety cabinet that speaks
and presents information clearly it
looks something like this and you'll
notice that there is quite a bit more
going on than a analog gauge or a
beeping light and so some of the things
that you should be aware of that modern
BSC is from lab Conoco include are a
filter life gauge to tell you how long
your filters last now of course that
gauges in the last several several years
but it's important to know that you're
not using a BSC with a completely
imploded filter you'll also see
indications for the beacon of the
biosafety cabinets operation with its
blower on or off where airflow is moving
and how fast is moving to know that it's
within collaboration and you'll see here
all the lab Kongo models include a
screen right at the high level so not
only is that information very clear to
you it comes in eight languages even but
it's right at eye level so if you block
the sash and it cause an alert the the
display will explain to you how to
correct that without you having to go
find a manual or lean back and look
upwards at the top of the biosafety
cabinet for information so some of the
things that are important to know if
you're a BSC user or work with people
who do use PSCs are the functions that
are available beyond the screen on lab
chemical models that might include
things like the smart start features
where the biosafety cabinet can start up
and shut down automatically with with
the raising and lowering of the sash
also for users to understand if they are
going to be using a UV light how long
that UV light is set to run for
information that would be clearly
displayed on the screen also it's
important to just have an understanding
of what filter life and airflow means so
look at the certification sticker on
your biosafety cabinet and
look at what the biosafety cabinet is
displaying and make sure that your your
filter is not completely out of life if
you're using the BSC and make sure that
the airflow is matching what the the BSC
is supposed to be certified that our
systems will alarm to tell you when it
bit the system the biosafety cabinet is
out of range but it's important still to
do that double check and confirmation
also you should be aware of some of the
alarms that can happen and understand
what they mean
our models include screens like this I
tell you what the alarm is and how to
correct it and and if you're not
familiar with these alerts and alarms
it's strongly recommended to become a
little bit more familiar with your BSC
so that you can react when you're in the
middle of an experiment potentially with
something hazardous the last thing I'm
going to talk about is being a
responsible user so a bit of a dovetail
off of the last slides which is to say
that you should be aware of not only in
how your BSC performs and what type of
BSC is but how to use it properly
this this section may depend a vary
depending on what kind of work you're
performing the biosafety cabinet but in
general there are a couple of things to
that all users should be aware of and
the first thing is to make sure that
your BSC has a current certification
label certification is a process that
typically happens once every year or
sooner and it's a process done by a
third party that checks they're trained
professionals to check the airflow going
into the BSC as in flow the down flow
sterile air and to make sure that the
filters don't have any holes in them so
that your work is safe you are faced and
that your filters aren't leaking any
biohazardous materials in and out of the
BSC once you know that certification is
present turn the BSE on and let it sit
for a little while to stabilize its air
flow and allow for the environment to
clean up and also be aware that you
should really assume that a biosafety
cabinet may always be contaminated
certainly if you work with some sort of
cell cultures and you've been growing a
cell line for some time the last thing
you want to do is to have that line in
affected so it's important to just
always assumed that the biosafety
cabinet needs to be disinfected prior to
beginning work one note I want to make
that I hit on earlier is on the inside
of the BSC on the ceiling is directly
behind the grill is the HEPA filter that
is the supply hepa filter if you're
going to if you are going to wipe that
grill down be sure to spray a towel and
then wipe do not spray the filter
because disinfectants and liquids can
damage and contaminate supply filters
okay so while working it's important to
always treat the BSC as a is a precious
sterile environment so anything that you
bring into the environment whether it's
yourself whether it's materials make
sure that you disinfect them prior to
entering the BSC definitely want to
focus on working at least fifteen
centimetres or four to six inches inside
the biosafety cabinet so as to prevent
or limit the risk of bringing bacteria
or other contaminants out of the BSC and
onto your person or onto the outside of
the BSC the last thing you want to do is
self inoculate while working with
hazardous microbiology and working
within the BSC is a physical advantage
to keeping that bacteria and other
hazards microbiology in the inside the
biosafety cabinet you should also plan
to work aseptic Lee and that means
working in a single direction so if you
remember the diagram showing sterile
down flow air moving in a straight
uniform direction working aseptically is
the same concept just with user habits
so you can see this diagram or we've got
all sorts of our consumables on the left
and you're working in the center and
then moving to the right with your waste
and doing this is just a simple process
of keeping the environment as
contaminant free as possible keeping a
clean area clean and keeping a dirty
area dirty and of course if you have
open materials keep them capped it not
only will it help with keeping them
contamination free but it will also
reduce the risk of escape of something
from one of those containers or vials or
tubes or plates
to your person on your other work on and
injured as a health risk to yourself
also if you spill be a good steward of
your biosafety cabinet and your work and
cleaning it up immediately don't leave
it for the next person who might use the
BSC don't allow it to impactor your
yourself by getting all into your gloves
and and definitely don't allow it to
impact your work so just a quick
run-through of what a still in a
biosafety cabinet might look like no
different than any other spill in the
laboratory use absorbent cleaning grade
materials so such as an absorbent pad
dampen with an in disinfectant try to
wipe in a fashion that moves inward so
as to contain but not spread what you
spill and definitely depending on what
you're working with and what cleaning
you're working with use a chemical that
has a contact time that's suitable to
kill your your the organism now in this
diagram you'll see a bottle of Clorox
that's bleach be mindful that bleach is
not a good suitable fit for stainless
steel as it will rust it there are lots
of sporicidal and other disinfectants
out there that are suitable for almost
every microbiology a microbiology
microbiological organism that can be
used to to kill and remove from most
films once you've done treat the waste
obviously is hazardous waste
rediff infect the services in the area
swap your gloves out wash your hands and
then resume work it's it's imperative
follow these steps to protect yourself
and also to protect your work once
you're done working in a biosafety
cabinet there are also some basic steps
that should always be considered and
that includes disinfecting any materials
before you bring them out of the BSC
followed by a full disinfection of the
BSE work area and that means cleaning
the visible surfaces cleaning underneath
the work surface as needed and in
cleaning areas that look like they might
be prone to a collection of more
contamination from your work it's always
a good idea to close the sash once
you're done with
infecting the entire BSC if you have a
UV light certainly you can use it as a
secondary disinfection it should always
come as a secondary disinfection to
chemical disinfection and and you may
also choose to use a night smart mode
which is a low-flow airflow
feature on a lab Conoco pscs that keeps
the environment clean and free of
hazards by pushing a small amount of air
through the HEPA filter on the supply
into the work environment just a couple
of other quick notes to consider if
you're a user that falls into the
category of using more than just cell
culture materials so maybe you need a
microscope for your work consider where
that's going into the BSC
and if you need some special
considerations so here you'll see a user
working with probably non pathogenic
organisms on the open bench and there
are microscopes that are you know can
also fit into BSC s but you'll see here
there's a there's a problem with this
design where the microscope is actually
crossing the barrier from the inside of
the BSC to the outside which could
potentially impact user so if you're a
user like this consider a task fit BSC
such as our cell logic models which
integrate a microscope safely through
the glass in the sash so as to remove
contamination from the BSC out of the
out of the the containment environment
and to make using a microscope more
comfortable another thing to hit on is
maintenance and this may be one of the
lesser thought of components of
biosafety cabinets but it's important to
have set schedules for daily weekly
monthly and yearly processes so we
talked about checking the certification
label definitely check the filter life
and disinfect and and make sure that if
you see an issue with a biosafety
cabinet you report it to the person who
is responsible for managing that
equipment because you're sitting in this
webinar learning more about biosafety
cabinets you're armed with extra
information to keep yourself safe but
perhaps you work with another person who
might not have as much experience and
they may not know all of these things so
think of think of the people you share
your equipment with and make sure that
they're aware about things that may not
be right with the biosafety cabinets so
on a weekly basis
do a deeper clean certainly inspect and
clean under the work surface I guarantee
if it has not been done in a week you
will find at least something down there
and it's always good to just to make
sure that there's no kimwipes or
or contamination that's down there that
could turn into something more
significant and impact a BSc or work
that takes place in the biosafety
cabinets on a yearly basis or sooner you
definitely want to approach having the
biosafety cabinet certified and you'll
see a label like this on every BSC
that's certified this one happens to be
from a national certifier lots of
different recommendations and companies
out there who do fantastic certification
jobs and this will tell you the type of
model the certification status and the
next time the certification is due and
these are all important stats to be
aware of so that you can work on a BSC
that you know is current and tested in
safe to use so those are the three
concepts key areas that you can look at
and train yourself on and train others
on to become more friendly and aware of
your biosafety cabinets so that they can
improve safety within the laboratory and
and so at this point I want to open it
up to questions on any three of the
topics or other biosafety cabinet
questions that you may have
and thank you David for that informative
presentation and we will now start the
live Q&A portion of the webinar if you
have any questions you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on that
answer a question box located on the far
left of your screen will answer as many
of your questions as we have time for so
like we have some questions already
coming in from our audience members our
first one David is my biosafety cabinet
doesn't display filter life is there a
way to know how long my filters will
last and in the process of building a
new buck I'm sorry oh let me tackle that
first question it's a great question so
so if you have a biosafety cabinet that
does not have a display or does not show
filter status it can be very difficult
to assess the remaining filter life if
there's no press no digital gauge older
BSES
typically rely on a mini alert or
magnetic gauge and while it's an
indication that more loading of the
filters has taken place you should be
aware that every HEPA filter has a
different pressure load and tolerance to
it so if you replace a filter the next
filter you put into it may be fully
loaded at a different level than the
prior filter so it's best to keep
current certifications every year or
sooner with that style of BSC and and be
aware that it is only a rough
measurement of of where that BSC is in
terms of its filter life and it's fully
loaded capacity for those filters great
thank you
and our next question is our lab has
many different protocols that require
BSC S is our type a suitable for all
types of BSC activities another good
question
so type a to be SES cover a lot of
laboratory uses on the microbiology side
which you the question you need to ask
yourself evaluating your protocols is
the content of chemicals within those
biosafety cabinets and those protocols
that are happening in those biosafety
cabinets if you're using a medium to
large volume of chemicals making a
solution maybe you have an open pan of
chemicals that's used for a process
those are those are instances where you
really really really want to
look at how much recirculated chemical
vapor is occurring and whether or not
that's going to reach an explosive limit
or even close to an explosive limit and
if the answer is yes there is a risk for
it for high concentration of chemicals
then you probably want to look at a type
C 1 BSC that can be an A or B depending
on use or if you always have a large
volume of chemicals and you can
facilitate the installation of a b2 that
may also be a costly but a potential
option
thank you our next question is my BSC
hasn't been certified in a long time
who do I contact for this service and
how much will it cost
so certification in the North America is
done by third-party groups and so the
first the first thing you should do is
stop using that BSC and if you don't
have a existing company that provides
certification to your to your entire
university or company then you can
probably do a quick Google search but
more more effectively just give lab
Conoco a call and we can link you up
with some certification options in your
area now once you identify that person
certification is a fairly inexpensive
cost typically depending on where you
are somewhere between 100 to 200 dollars
thank you for that and I
I think our audience members again for
their great questions coming in David
since there is a glass shield is there
any need or requirement for the clinical
laboratory technologist to wear eye
protection while performing work in a
BSc
so I'll serve up was saying that more
PPE is almost never a bad thing but you
need to do a risk assessment of what's
happening in the biosafety cabinet with
respect to how things are being handled
if there's a risk for era civilization
in which you should also obviously
consider a restoration protection
measurement
I would also strongly urge looking at
the CDC's guide for for bacteria and
viruses other pathogens as they very
specifically explicitly discuss the
types of PPE recommendations per type of
organism so if you look and find
something you know is going to be an
aerosol aerosolization risk almost
always it's obviously going to have
respiration and eye protection thank you
very much and David what is a solution
to strong stool order that comes from a
stool specimen inside a BSc - so-so
stool samples are are not at risk of
being breaching explosive limit they
just have a noxious odor that can be
unpleasant and so typically a type A to
B se would be recommended to handle that
odor you can either choose to canopy
vents the BSE to the outside or you
might choose to explore using a trace
odor filter with carbon filtration in it
though you may need to evaluate the cost
of how often the stool samples are being
used and whether or not a frequent
replacement of a carbon filter is
economical versus the cost of venting a
biosafety cabinets
thank you for that and here's another
great question is it allowed to
disinfect with h2o to dust
so h2o - or hydrogen peroxide is a
suitable disinfectant it is it is
typically actually used to decontaminate
an entire biosafety cabinet so a
certifier if they have to replace a
filter or a blower will use a couple of
different methods formaldehyde chlorine
dioxide or hydrogen peroxide gas and
it's an effective steroids when used
properly so yes it is suitable and
acceptable to use within a BSc thank you
for that and the number of users David
is it safe to have two users using BSC
at one time it's certainly not
recommended you have to consider
multiple things one the size of the BSC
especially for you were to put two users
crowded together will impact and
restrict a lot of the free-flowing air
both down flow air and inflow air but I
- the person asking this question I also
urge you to consider the impacts that
two users may have on each other moving
air from their hands back and forth and
potentially cross contaminating each
other's work
so when possible it's always strongly
recommended to work as one user per
biosafety cabinet especially if you are
working with known bio hazards
thank you for that and I want to thank
our audience again these are great
questions coming in it always makes a
great live presentation when is it
necessary to use a ULP a filter so an
open filter or ultra low particulate air
filter is similar and near identical
construction to a HEPA filter they use
borosilicate glass fibers and they're
typically just more densely woven
borosilicate fibers so the rating is
more effective at smaller particulates
but in actuality at least let me speak
first of biologicals if you're working
with biologicals almost all of them are
much larger than the 0.3 micron most
penetrating particle size so all the
filter rarely does anything but only
clog and require more frequent changing
when just strictly handling have
biologicals and other similar and
particulates the all put filters do have
some uses in instances where perhaps
you're looking for a nanotechnology
application but what's not different
about them is their ability to capture
materials or particulate that are
smaller than 0.3 microns so if you look
at a HEPA filter the larger a particle
is versus point three microns the more
affected that have the filter will trap
it but as you get smaller than point
three microns the HEPA filter is also
equally effective and at trapping small
particulates because they flutter around
as they go through the filter so if you
look at recommendations for trapping the
things that would be handling in a
biosafety cabinet a HEPA filter is
entirely suitable for just about every
single application and most certainly
for all biological applications and ulpa
filters will only cost more and more
importantly it will load faster and
require more frequent decontamination
and HEPA filter replacements with little
to no value for a user
and speaking of filters one audience
member wants to know why the HEPA filter
have an expiration date so great
question HEPA filters have a very long
lifetime especially when treated nicely
they're made out of borosilicate innards
glass as a media but they they contain a
gasket on them that that is required to
seal that entire filter frame to
whatever the application might be
whether it's in a clean room ceiling or
a biosafety cabinets internal airflow
plenum and by having that that gasket on
there it is it is the failure point for
a HEPA filter so the the stated ultra
light from a manufacturer may be ex
stays it does vary by manufacturer which
is why it's important to evaluate and
have frequent certifications on your BSC
because that certification process will
directly look at the HEPA filter and
whether or not it a leak has generated
whether through the media of the filter
the glass fibers or through the gasket
itself
thank you and is a UV light and
effective decontaminate it depends
heavily debated question in the u.s. the
CDC would tell you that they don't
recommend using the UV light the reality
is that the the answer is a gray area
you first have to evaluate if what
you're working with is effectively
killed or are removed or not removed
like killed off by UV light so some
bacteria certainly will be more
susceptible to UV light than others so
for instance like tuberculosis which is
a waxy cell wall it's very resistant to
UV light and you but in short it
certainly is not necessarily a bad thing
it's an extra thing to maintain but it
should always be used as a secondary
disinfection measure after chemical
disinfection with a suitable D
disinfection solution thank you for that
and similarly another audience member
says I am ABM ET is there any special
steps to replace the UV or working light
and do I need to perform a
decontamination process so the UV light
on a biosafety cabinet from lab Congo is
located in the work zone so it is in the
contaminated space so prior to doing any
work you want to first make sure that
the inside of the biosafety cabinet is
disinfected fully and I means wiping
down all those services including the UV
light to change that bulb the process is
fairly simple on our PSCs it's just
unplugging the power and then removing
the bulbs and replacing the bulb and
then resetting the UV timer that's an
important step because the UV light has
an own lifetime it's typically about
6,000 hours and lab Tonko units include
a countdown timer to alert users when
the UV light is no longer as potent or
effective as it once was but the process
is very simple
and David how long should one use the UV
light again it depends heavily on the
organism that's being used you can set
it to run for a very short duration of
time or you can run it for an unlimited
period of time it just depends on on the
virus of bacteria that you're looking at
and there are lots of different papers
out there for many different bacteria
and viruses and other pathogens or
contaminants and a BSc so my
recommendation is to do some reading on
that and decide if the UV light is an
effective decontamination platform for
those organisms and and certainly again
just to reiterate that chemical
disinfection should be used as a primary
disinfection source first thank you
again David and I just want to remind
audience members that any question is
not answered today will be answered via
email we have time for a couple more
questions David is there a laser a
magnet helic a gauge reading that will
indicate that the BSC is out of
specification example a 10% of the
certified reading unfortunately the
answer is no so the magnetic gauge on
all BSES whether thirty years ago or
today there's some still use them all it
is reading is that the the pressure
differential on the blower or the hepa
filters to show you how loaded those
filters are but that that number that
that pressure increases as the filters
load and so to combat that the drop in
air flow that occurs as a result you can
adjust the blower upwards and and but
the value doesn't have any doesn't have
any way to tell you what the airflow is
in the BSC there may be a separate
depending on the model of BSC there may
be a separate airflow monitor or sensors
of something something else may checking
that and alerting a user but there's
really no easy way to extrapolate what
the magnet hila gauge is telling you
other than the filters are loading and
have loaded more than they
were previously and and should the BSC's
be checked with the actual equipment
that is usually in the hood it seems we
are told they empty the hood to empty
the hood before certification yeah so so
biosafety tenets when they're they're
designed and tested by NSF and ourselves
and others are manufactured and tested
with no equipment inside of them that is
how most certifiers test them if you
have a particularly bulky material or
perhaps a microscope you can certainly
go back and have that certifier test at
BSC with that equipment in there which
will help you get a better understanding
of what's happening when that equipment
is loaded I'm familiar with the concept
of certifiers asking for everything to
be pulled out if you have a large piece
a box add something large in there
there's certainly nothing wrong with
having them evaluate that piece of
equipment inside the BSC to get a better
understanding of what the the biosafety
cabinet is doing now
I would I would extend that comment to
large pieces of equipment are really
dedicated pieces of equipment but if you
have pipette tip boxes or pipe a track
in there those that you know they can
move around so so commonly and easily
that it's kind of difficult to get a
good assessment from a certifier with
stuff that might move around so just
take a take a look at what's in your BSC
and and evaluate have it have a
discussion with your certifier they're
um they're very experienced and trained
individuals who can give you a lot of
information and insight on what you
might experience or how you might even
better place the piece of equipment
within your BSC to limit cross
contamination and promote from personnel
protection
David thank you so much and we have time
for one more question
once we finish our work with BSC do you
recommend leaving it on for a few
minutes after cleaning definitely yes I
there is no harm in letting a biosafety
cabinet run for additional time if I
didn't have that bullet point in there I
will add it immediately after just to be
clear but definitely the more time you
give the biosafety cabinet to sit in a
state before you start using it after
you start stop using it the more likely
it's going to clean up any residual
particulates and contaminants within
that set space
thank you so much David and do you have
any final comments for all audience
members today I just want to say thanks
for everyone for your participation I
saw there are a lot of questions that
came in some we were able to answer a
lot more that I will respond to
individually if you have additional
questions that come up certainly feel
free to reach out my information I think
is attached to this presentation or call
and contact lab can code directly we
have lots of people in the office who
are experienced with biosafety cabinets
and specific applications that can help
walk through tailored questions to your
lab or your environment your BSE types
no matter the type of biosafety cabinet
so just want to reiterate that or here
as a resource for you to to make sure
you're operating within your BSES
safely and keeping everyone safe who
might touch them so otherwise thank you
so much for everyone for listening and I
look forward to seeing you all on a
future webinar hopefully absolutely and
thank you again David and thank you for
your important research before we go I
want to thank the audience for joining
us today and for their interesting
questions questions we did not have time
to answer today or those submitted
during the on-demand period will be
addressed from the speaker via contact
information you provided at the time of
registration I'd also like to thank lab
roots and our sponsor lab panco for
underwriting today's educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
labyrinth will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share this email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time bye bye for
now